pokemon legends arceus has confirmed an
interesting fact about how pokemon are
captured elden rings should be easier to
beat and more
pokemon legends arceus is out now and a
snippet of new pokemon lore revealed in
arceus has set gaming reddit ablaze
supposedly pokemon themselves possess
the odd power to shrink themselves down
and that's how they fit into the
pokeballs we need a pokemon professor
here to see if that clashes against any
existing lore prior to arceus the
general body of players assumed that
pokeballs possess the technology to
minimize pokemon but apparently not it's
something pokemon are just born with the
random ability to shrink themselves this
would explain their near invisibility in
grass until you bump into them but also
doesn't explain why some pokemon are so
resistant to getting in the pokeball
they're so well suited for it like
they're literally equipped with the
capacity to live in a small sphere one
reddit user posted a great question and
said why does the move minimize exist if
literally all of them can do it and not
to play game freak's advocate here but
one theory could be that the combat move
minimize is different from the ability
to shrink themselves down in any case as
more pokemon games get released and
there's already a lot of them the lore
probably will only get more complicated
and take unexpected turns this likely
won't be the only new info players will
scratch their heads over or in this case
develop a thousand message long comment
threat debating and mulling over the new
lore
with only weeks standing between the
highly anticipated elden ring and its
ravenous fans game director hidetaka
miyazaki has opened up about the
difficulty discourse that has long
surrounded from software games from
software frequently draws the ire of
some gamers who feel its popular
role-playing games which include the
beloved and demanding dark souls series
provide too steep of a challenge and
should include difficulty options
however some fans of the aptly named
souls-like genre disagree with that
assessment feeling strongly that the
games benefit from their cryptic design
choices and precise punishing combat
from software itself has long stood by
its stance too imploring all gamers to
embrace the challenge so that they can
feel an equal sense of reward by
overcoming it despite this speaking in
an interview with playstation blog
miyazaki made it clear that he believes
the conversation is still one worth
having he said quote it's a valid
discussion i feel like our approach to
these games not just eldon ring is to
design them to encourage the player to
overcome adversity we don't try to force
difficulty or make things hard for the
sake of it we want players to use their
cunning study the game memorize what's
happening and learn from their mistakes
miyazaki went on to share that he
believes the barrier of entry has been
lowered in elden ring as well due to
design choices that now provide
additional player agency and that he
hopes quote players embrace that idea of
receiving help from others he also
promised that the multiplayer function
of the game has been streamlined to put
an emphasis on working together to
overcome elton ring's toughest
challenges with this in mind miyazaki
feels confident that elton ring will
have the highest completion rate in from
software's souls-like library miyazaki's
interview also included confirmation
that eldon ring will feature a new game
plus mode and multiple endings two
components that have become a core part
of what makes from software games
endlessly replayable for die hard fans
the tech savvy killjoy a character in
riot games tactical shooter valorent was
recently shown in a tweet enjoying a
piece of nft art which raised some
eyebrows among more than a few fans riot
quickly deleted the tweet and has since
issued an apology the tweet was made by
the official german valorant twitter
account as a way to highlight killjoy's
hometown of berlin and spotlight
computer-generated art according to
riot's apology the team didn't realize
the artwork featured in the tweet by
artist martin hora was an nft the
statement tweeted out by the german
valerian twitter account reads quote
since killjoy loves programming we
wanted to introduce you to computer
generated art from around the world
however we were not aware that the
selected work was an nft in no way did
we intend to include nfts as a part of
killjoy's work and hobbies fans in the
responses to the clarification tweets
seem to be relieved that one of the
game's fan favorite characters was not
into nfts but it's currently unclear
what riot's overall stance on the
technology is if you want to know more
about nfts especially in games i suggest
you go check out my video on this
channel where i talk all about it
so how do you feel about this new
pokemon lore are you excited or against
elden ring being easy to beat let me
know in the comments and make sure to
like subscribe and come back next week
for more gamespot news have a great
weekend
[Music]